these four families are preparing for a
time in the not so distant future when
they believe water food and fuel will be
scarce
when the grid goes down this could be
our food source we have three different
sources of water without good water
you're not going to survive long
they fear a world where money is
worthless and there is no rule of law
i'm not going to look like prey each
expects an impending disaster that will
destroy the world as we know it and have
gone to extreme lengths so that when the
end of days arrive
they
will be prepared to survive
i want my kids to do all the fun things
that kids should do
but i also want to learn practical
skills prepping has eliminated some
hobbies i don't golf i don't bowl i
probably have about six or seven
thousand dollars in food our experts
will assess their extensive preparations
and decide if they are truly ready for
the ultimate life or death test
or if they're just
flirting with disaster
cheers
to the end of the world
[Music]
dennis and danielle mcclung live in a
suburb of phoenix with their two
children he is a web designer and she is
a
nurse art and they are a typical
middle-class family
except
go
i'm preparing for a coronal mass
ejection in 2012.
prepping guides everything we do
prepping has definitely changed our life
you could say i'm obsessed with
studying and preparing for the end of
the world
in 2012 earth will be bombarded by
coronal mass ejection this bombardment
will knock our neighborhood and the
world's electrical grid down we'll have
a couple days worth of water
about a week's worth of food and in 30
days our neighborhoods can be pure
pandemonium
coronal mass ejections are powerful
eruptions on the sun that break free of
the solar atmosphere
if these masses of plasma reach the
earth
it could destroy our electrical grid
which touches every facet of modern life
[Music]
we consider ourselves suburban preppers
we happen to live in a desert city so we
have a lot of challenges that most folks
don't have as preppers the doomsday
scenario for 2012 for me would be that
it got so chaotic outside that we would
have to leave our home and not be able
to take care of our family
let's say our family's sitting here in
our home
some night in 2012 and the colonel mass
ejection hits the first thing that we'll
notice is all the lights go off that's
really the least of our worries because
we only have a couple days worth of
water and after that the next thing to
run out would be food
and then probably about seven days after
the coronal mass ejection hits we have
no more modern health care after that
things get real hairy we could
potentially have 140 nuclear meltdowns
in america
in 2009 dennis moved his family from a
small apartment to his suburban dream
home
a bedroom for each kid a modern kitchen
and an arizona necessity
a backyard pool
but not for swimming our home it came
with a large empty rundown pool and what
we did is we framed it and converted it
into a solar-powered aquaponic
greenhouse as a part of our plan to be
as self-sufficient as we can by 2012
cinnamon yeah
oh sorry that's okay
all right
we keep our chickens over our pond and
they give us eggs every day and the
chicken waste drops into the pond and
feeds the pond plants and the algae
which in return feeds the fish and we
eat the fish every day and the water
from the fish in returns provides
nutrients for the plants so basically
we've converted our pool into a
self-sufficient urban greenhouse in
preparation for a coronal mass ejection
in 2012.
originally our old pool was a 16 by 30
rectangle that was nine and a half feet
deep and about four and a half feet at
the shallow end so it's about 500 square
feet and in this 500 square feet we're
able to grow
thousands of tilapia fish
and the amazing thing about the tilapia
is they can have 1200 babies at a time
and they're ready to reproduce four to
six weeks later so they can grow
exponentially
dad can we go fishing sure let's go
let's get the pool i'll race you come on
you got it come on kaden
you got it pull it rail it in
wow
that's a big one
if the food supply is disrupted in 2012
or 2013 dennis will have his own
self-sustaining food source
but until then with over a thousand fish
in the deep end of his pool
he has to go fishing every day
because his family eats tilapia nearly
every single night
we could make tilapia lasagna tilapia
tacos tilapia stir-fry it's nice because
it takes on the taste of whatever we're
cooking with we've been eating fish
pretty much daily and we haven't got
tired of it yet
the tilapia water is carried up with a
pump using minimal electricity that's
powered by solar panels and then it's
distributed with gravity to the plants
basically what we do is we grow fish
and we use that nutrient-rich water to
also grow produce
we have bok choy we have grapes
blackberries
peppers carrots broccoli we're trying to
live self-sustainable
enough to survive an apocalypse
the heart of dennis's food production
system is the minuscule miracle plant
called duckweed
it not only purifies their water
but since it has as much protein as soy
they feed it to the fish
their livestock
and are exploring ways that as a last
resort
they can eat it themselves
you know this stuff's getting so thick
we have so much of it we should uh make
a protein shake out of it
that's a good idea just dry it out yeah
what i mean
here
ready
tastes like lettuce tastes like lettuce
in the event that a coronal mass
ejection does strike kitchen appliances
powered by electricity will be useless
danielle uses the sun oven for
everything from baking bread
to making sun-dried tomatoes and even to
dehydrate duckweed for a protein shake
[Music]
we have eight hens that we raise in our
pool the city we allow us to attend and
we only have eight so we try to stay
under the radar as much as possible
kaden takes personal pride in being
responsible for the chickens he feeds
and waters the chickens
he also collects the eggs usually we get
about five to eight eggs a day
three brown right now
good boy the mcclung backyard menagerie
is not limited to just fish and fowl
they also keep some unusual but
practical pets
so that even without electricity to run
their refrigerator they will still have
fresh milk daily
we have two west african pygmy goats and
they provide our family with a half a
gallon of milk a day milk milk milk
those are her utters
my son kaden actually named the girl
honey and our daughter named the boy
schatzy because if we name our goats
then they're not considered livestock
like game of elk
yes and the city we live in doesn't
allow goats unless you have 35 000
square feet of land which we don't have
so by letting our kids name the goats
we've actually got to keep them
dennis is constantly looking to the
future thinking and planning how we can
best augment his already extensive food
water and energy preparations for as he
calls it
the end of the world as we know it
this is our next big project
what we're basically going to do is rip
off all the shingles you see here and
coat it with a thin layer of rubberized
asphalt and aluminum and what that'll do
is actually reflect a lot of the heat
back save us energy and it'll also
enable us to catch thousands of gallons
of rain water which will replace our
potable water usage this is our a very
big project for us because in 2012 when
the coronal mass ejection hits we'll be
the only folks on the block with a way
to provide our family with water and
electricity as well as food
i enjoy doing stuff like golf but since
i've been a prepper i really haven't had
much time so i do miss a little bit of
what i call normal life
but i feel it's my duty as a parent to
be able to provide for my kids no matter
what happens the worst case scenario
that we can see is the breakdown of the
fabric that holds our society together i
could see things getting really bad
people shooting each other riots looting
uh pure anarchy
so in order to get through this we have
to think a little different than most
preppers because we're thinking about
providing for ourselves as long as
possible being truly self-sufficient
cheers
to the end of the world
to survive 2012 2013 dennis and danielle
have created a veritable eden in their
backyard
but how will they survive if unforeseen
events force them to leave and go it
alone on the road all right who's this
elephant we're no longer safe to stay
here
and what will our expert think of their
chances of survival
i'm a typical phoenix suburban housewife
except i'm preparing for the end of the
world
look what we got dennis and danielle are
scared that if the grid shuts down
because of coronal mass ejections the
nearby nuclear power plant safety
measures will fail and it will melt down
in preparing for the end of the world as
with anything else practice makes
perfect so they practice practice
practice
go
[Music]
dennis's goal is to have them get their
nuclear chemical and biological suits on
in under six minutes
really a family has to know how to use
these and if you don't have them in the
event of a nuclear catastrophe you'd be
out of luck
i'm going to beat mama i think the boys
are going to win caden
all right guys we did it all right
yeah
katie you did a great job i'm very proud
of you
when relatives come to visit the
mcclunks they sleep in what could be the
safest guest bedroom in all of arizona
we decided to convert our guest bedrooms
to a survival supply room we've had a
lot of friends and neighbors come over
and
you know think everything is pretty
normal until they walk into this room
and it kind of takes them back
a bit
we keep our gas masks in order this one
is my daughter vedas this is my son
cadence this is my gas mask and this is
my husband dennis's this is our
emergency coagulant if i was to get shot
my wife could pour that on me or someone
could pour it on me and prevent me from
losing all my blood
this
is a minor surgery kit so if i need to
do any sutures or any minor surgeries i
have that ability what we have here is a
portable toilet so if we had to go the
bathroom in here we could bag it up and
keep it separate believe it or not poor
hygiene could be one of the biggest
killers in uh if something was to be
wrong with the grid
some families go camping for a little r
r but in an emergency dennis feels he
will have to get his family out of the
house and out of phoenix as quickly and
as well prepared as possible there's no
space for hot dogs and marshmallows in
dennis's bug-out bag
a 72-hour kit or a bug out bag is
basically everything you would need for
about three days you got to think about
cooking and fuel and
navigation
water certainly
hygiene
you're going to want to have personal
means of protection
the 72 hour kick could be the difference
between life and death
[Music]
to us preparing is a family affair what
we do is we get our kids used to
prepping with us we'll take them
backpacking we'll actually pack out the
bug out bags my son has his favorite
survival whistle
and we we get used to it that way the
kids aren't scared gotta get the bottom
of her face in first honey when disaster
strikes that's when panic strikes
and that's when you don't clearly think
but if you're used to doing something if
it's second nature then your mind will
be a little bit clearer when you need it
the most we're very upfront with our
children elephant
elephants we try to let our children get
the skills that we have and pass that
along without scaring them or alarming
them you want to carry this one yeah
okay good girl come on let's go guys
some of the other things we do is we
pack up our bug out bags and we head out
and we try to stay in the wilderness for
days just to see if we have what it
takes to really survive
we don't think that we're a doom and
gloom family we don't think that we live
in fear uh
what we have done is prepared ourselves
for the events in 2012 and 2013 however
we don't let that be an overlying factor
in our lives
dennis as you predicted a coronal mass
ejection hits the earth in 2012 or 2013.
your food and water preparations were
boldly planned and ingeniously and
effectively executed
you have wisely provided yourself with
the ability to fend off minor threats
medical supplies and proper sanitation
however by not integrating your
neighbors into your plan your food
supplies might make you a valuable
target
our expert advises you to include your
neighbors in your planning and help them
develop their own to increase your
chances of survival
well i don't really agree with that we
have a lot of support from our neighbors
there's a lot of people who would come
to us
to expecting us to help and and what our
position would be to do is because we
know what they should be doing is direct
their energies because we need to work
together as community and get through
2012.
although dennis disagrees with the
assessment he has subsequently met with
more neighbors
inviting them over for tours of his pool
and teaching them prepper strategies
lisa bedford and her family live in the
suburbs of phoenix but she's not a
typical suburban soccer mom carpooling
her kids to games we have no other
interest or purpose in life other than
preparing for some armageddon she is
busy prepping her family for the end of
the world i want my kids to do all the
fun things that kids should do
but i also want them to learn practical
skills but has she done enough i don't
know how i'm going to eat this when the
world ends
lisa bedford and her husband have a
daughter
son cat and dog they are a typical
suburban phoenix family except i'm
afraid our country faces serious
hyperinflation they
are preppers
i think to a non-prepper
what we do would seem like an obsession
but i'm not obsessed by anything i'm
just prepping for collapse of the
economy
bringing on hyperinflation and higher
prices our family started prepping close
to three years ago
we began to see friends lose jobs the
price of gasoline going up the price of
electricity going up the very basics
that we need to survive those prices
just skyrocketing
and we realized that there really could
be something very significant and very
serious coming to end the days of a very
prosperous america
so we took that gut feeling and we began
to just act on it and we first started
out just by going to the grocery store
and buying everyday groceries okay i
think we're good on tomato soup and
chicken noodle soup i began to do
research and that's when i realized i
needed to stock up on basics like wheat
and rice add that to my food storage
now don't overflow it
we've used soda bottles for a long time
fema
gives their official approval for this
kind of plastic for uh food storage i
don't know how i'm gonna eat this when
the world ends
the world's not going to end
you act like it no it's not going to end
we involve our kids in what we do
simply by not having it be anything
abnormal or out of the ordinary
if i ever yell get your bug out bags
kids you'll know what to do people call
me a suburban prepper but i really
prefer to think of myself as just your
typical suburban mom who has an eye on
the future
and i like to think that i can prepare
for the future just a little bit every
day
the prepper movement is growing
exponentially stores that once only sold
to restaurants are now welcoming
individuals who are trying to stock up
today lisa shops at honeyville farms a
store that caters specifically to her
slightly extreme freeze-dried dehydrated
and bulk needs
how many people are in your family okay
four four two kids
initially we started selling to bakeries
tortillas restaurants and in the last
few years we've tried to target the
customer who's the prepper so you've got
four months on hand
i do
good and what's your
your goal how long are you wanting to do
you know what probably
the
big long term goal would be a year the
people with who are looking for bulk
items and freeze-dried fruits vegetables
the freeze-dried meats things like that
will last a long time we're talking
about 10 to 15 years on most of this
stuff and you can freeze dry almost
anything there's a lot more people who
are very urgent about getting to that
stage of preparation because they feel
like something's coming probably the
craziest order i've seen is a single man
wanted an entire truckload of wheat so
that's 45 000 pounds of wheat just to
store for himself so a palette about
this size would be able to feed a family
of four
for a year and that's about 1200
calories so that's not that's not very
much so with two of those that'd be
closer to what your family would need
okay that's what i want
many preppers believe that four to six
months of extra food and water are the
basic provisions necessary to survive a
major disaster
but for some
finding alternative currency options is
just as important
i've covered my bases for a lot of
standard scenarios but really the
biggest disaster is hyperinflation and
so what we have done is just invest in
precious metals physical silver and gold
we've heard that buying junk silver
is maybe a good hedge against inflation
90 silver that would be u.s coinage
dated in 1964 and earlier they have uh
90 silver it is one of the cheapest ways
to buy silver uh today with silver at a
little over thirty dollars the ounce
uh one of these guys here would run you
about five dollars and thirty cents a
piece roughly this here
you know three thousand bucks worth of
silver or you can have this whole all
these bags and you can trade in one or
two or three at a time
so this is this bag has 400 quarters in
it it's a hundred dollars face value
uh and at today's market price that
would put it right around 2150 that bag
is 150
i'm a firm believer that the value of
the dollar is headed down yeah and uh if
that's the case then this stuff's a
no-brainer yeah yeah so look at that
here's 20
there's four quarters
the suburban moms don't want to think of
a time when their safe and secure
neighborhood might not be so safe and
secure but in a time of hyperinflation
desperate people large numbers of people
out of work and prices just skyrocketing
beyond what anyone can afford even the
safest neighborhoods may not be so safe
anymore we take the kids out shooting
maybe once a month sometimes twice a
month if the weather's nice okay so hold
that just like daddy showed you okay you
got it right in the middle very nice
very good
currently we feel safe in our
neighborhood point it down that way
but there is a concern if uh our
currency should collapse if there would
be hyperinflation that we might see an
increase in home invasions we might see
an increase in violent crimes just as
people when we're desperate i want my
kids to do all the fun things that kids
should do
but i also want them to learn practical
skills if everything hits the fan
they're going to be ready with these
shooting skills to either hunting or to
use defense
self-defense training is crucial but in
a world gone mad preppers believe that
those who remain hidden and are not
perceived as resource-rich targets will
be the ones to survive
that sometimes might mean getting food
delivered at night opsec stands for
operational security it's a military
term and it just means keeping your lips
zipped loose lips sink ships
and so for us we really don't talk a
whole lot about what we do i don't want
my household and my family to be in the
middle of someone else's bull's-eye as
they wonder where they're going to get
their next meal and realize oh the
bedfords have it
the truth is we are more like the
typical average family than not
lisa
our expert feels that you have stored
enough food to withstand the
destabilizing and debilitating effects
of hyperinflation for an initial four to
six month period
and are aggressively working to extend
that to a full year
most importantly you've begun to
purchase precious metals as a hedge
against the unchecked inflation you fear
but while focusing on hyperinflation
you have not totally planned for other
disasters and developed adequate
evacuation plans
nor chosen a location to move to
if your house is threatened
it would take a lot for us to decide to
bug out
um
given the constraints we have with
geography and climate
we happen to live surrounded by miles
and miles and miles of desert with not a
whole lot of routes out of phoenix a
hundred thousand people trying to get
out of phoenix in a summer
it would be a death trap
lisa has chosen to ignore our expert's
advice
she feels that because phoenix is
surrounded by miles of desert and there
are only three or four major exit routes
that additional evacuation plans
would be fruitless
in rural south carolina the cobblers and
hunts have united their families to live
work
and fight together to be able to shoot
any weapon that our retreat group has is
a must in the belief that we are on the
precipice of worldwide economic collapse
they make their own food just making
good gas right now so we can start the
truck
build their own vehicles and each if the
time should come
is prepared to defend their farm to the
death
lord you've blessed us with a beautiful
day we thank you for our friends we
thank you for the cobblers amen all
right
yes david kobler and scott hunt are best
friends and their families are extremely
close all right bon appetit they cook
together
eat together and
prep together
i have prep for a collapse of the
financial system this will cause crime
to increase hunger to increase
and a complete breakdown of law and
order
it will happen here
david is a committed prepper who lives
in rural south carolina
if the total economic meltdown he fears
occurs
he and four other like-minded families
plan to leave behind all their worldly
possessions and link up at a farm about
20 minutes from david's house
to form their own prepper community
i don't fear anything i prepare
by preparing it takes care of the fear
problem
scott he is a excellent guy you can give
him a pile of junk and he will make
something useful out of it that's why i
decided to team up with him and put my
life in his hand and he has put his life
in my hands
hey dave made it
hey scott david's expertise is in the
tactical being x military having a lot
of skills a lot of training in that area
all right your weapon is clear go ahead
and re-holster
mine is an engineering mine is in uh
designing all sorts of gizmos
while in iraq at the beginning of the
invasion i saw true hunger i saw people
fighting over my scraps my garbage
david believes american supermarkets
could not stay stocked and people could
not afford food if the economy collapsed
so he's taken just a few precautionary
measures to prepare for this eventuality
i probably have about six or seven
thousand dollars in food
[Music]
i am probably not an overboard prepper
it has taken me about two years to get
to this point of having this amount of
food i started just with canned goods
that you normally buy at the grocery
store whatever you eat and it worked out
from there
to now i'm stocking long-term storage
food
dehydrated food
a big thing that you need to make sure
you stock is
toilet paper it's used by everyone in
the world
we stock a two-year supply of toilet
paper more toilet paper
hey that's a good idea
dave's food supply is over the top but
that's been a good thing because it's
motivated me to catch up to him
my plans for food range from long-term
food storage to what i've been working
on for several years is growing our own
food
we're able to grow everything from wheat
to corn
to all sorts of vegetables
in anticipation of commodities prices
skyrocketing they raise cows for milk
chickens for eggs
and can slaughter either for their meat
scott grows 1200 pounds of wheat a year
and to make up for any shortfall of
available flour he puts his ten-year-old
daughter sarah and her much older
bicycle to work
okay
mommy need about four cups
my daughter is now grinding this wheat
on our bicycle wheat grinder i've built
it's a lot of work to hand grind it's a
lot easier to pedal with a bicycle and
so we're grinding this today and we're
going to make bread from it tomorrow
of course preppers don't live on bread
alone
so with a fan a broken refrigerator
plenty of duct tape and some ingenuity
scott has built a contraption to make
the ultimate survival food i'm looking
forward to this batch beef jerky
i take hot water from my wood boiler
outside and bring water in here about
180 degrees into the heat exchanger the
fan blows across the heat exchanger and
the hot air travels into an old
refrigerator and so all the hot air
blows across and then we just close it
up we allow a little bit of air to
escape
and in four hours we'll be eating jerky
we don't do this out of fear this is a
lifestyle for us we enjoy having a
year's supply of food it gives my
children a sense of security a human
being can only stay alive for a week
without water scott understands that
access to it
is crucial for their survival
we have three different sources of water
and five different ways to pump the
water up the hill without good water
you're not going to survive long
we have the hydraulic ram pumps to pump
water up on the hill
we have springs here's a solar panel
that i use to pump water out of a spring
and then a drilled well that i can get
drinking water out of that with a hand
pump
and so i know that i can get water out
of the ground for my family
if our economy totally collapses
oil gas and electricity could become
prohibitively expensive
or even
no longer available
scott and david are already preparing to
make use of a once traditional but now
quite unusual alternative of which they
have a seemingly massive supply
[Music]
we do just about everything we can off
of wood
from cooking to heating our home to
heating our water
including driving his truck
and here i have my gasifier the gasifier
extracts the gases out of wood and then
we take the the gases and run them
directly into an engine the gas comes up
the right side of the engine
and then i hook it into uh existing
carburetor and then the wood gas
carburetor mixes air in the wood gas in
about a 50 50 uh ratio that's pretty
much it it's pretty simple it's
processors have been around since the
world war ii
it's making good gas right now so we can
start the truck
all right we're running on wood we're
good to go
being able to go for an afternoon
joyride is nice but if their fears
materialize this retooled 1962 ford
pickup has been customized to hook up to
their generator so it can power up the
entire compound
[Music]
and this amount of wood about three
pounds of wood works out to be about one
kilowatt per hour of electricity and
with the wood i feel i have an
indefinite supply in this area our goal
here is to have enough fuel to run a
year about four hours a day keep the
freezers cold and to run any tools
machines welders whatever we need to run
back at the y2k they thought i was crazy
but now i don't hear that as much
i am definitely not crazy
i've seen a lot of things overseas and
that has motivated me and has shaped my
mindset today we have 9-1-1 to call
one day we might not have 9-1-1 so it
will be your responsibility to take care
of your security
in the event of a total economic
collapse scott and david anticipate that
they will come under attack from roving
bands of marauders and that they will
have to protect what they have built
here
if you have no plan you will be in
serious trouble because
there will be no help coming
in rural south carolina scott hunt and
david kobler are making vast
preparations to combat their greatest
fear
a possible worldwide economic collapse
they've spent years and invested
thousands into building their
self-sufficient proper compound
however all could be for naught if
they're unable to protect it from the
attackers who did not have the foresight
to prepare
if you don't have food
you're going to die if you don't have
firearms someone can take all your food
so to me you have to balance that
between firearms and food david kobler
owns many guns and thousands of rounds
of ammunition frequently he runs a
firearm training session that every man
woman and child must participate in so
that they are prepared for that fateful
day when they are faced with the
ultimate survival decision kill
or be killed
if you don't shoot every day you do get
rusty this is a perishable skill that
you have to work on always
i have multiple firearms each firearm is
a tool in my toolbox
that's it
perfect you can go ahead and pull it
back like we did to make it easier for
you
feel comfortable put it's gonna be a
hair trigger now relax and do when
you're ready
to be able to shoot any weapon that our
retreat group has is a must
i've never shot an ar-15 before
i have four ar-15s
one for each family member this weapon
is important to me because it is a
combat multiplier combat multiplier is
something that makes you stronger than
you actually are
fear is really not even a word in my
vocabulary fear will paralyze you and
hold you one spot
there will be a lot of people with
nothing that will take what you have
i will defend to the death
because uh this is my food for my family
[Music]
55 acres is an almost impossible area to
defend effectively
to overcome this
david has formulated a plan that creates
a smaller perimeter of defense
we've decided to condense it at night
and only watch about five or six acres
today i'm looking for spots where we can
put some more trip wires these small
devices are combat multipliers
they make us feel stronger and look
stronger this is a natural trail through
the creek
if someone comes through this area
they're going to trip the device
so if it is a threat we can deal with it
david's extensive combat training has
taught him that in order to have the
upper hand in a conflict over a larger
number of attackers
he needs to see them
before they
see him we have played some lpo ps in
the perimeter an lpop is a listening
post during the night and an observation
post during the day so we can see people
coming you can clearly see there's room
for two guys to shoot out if necessary
this is a field phone connected to our
base retreat with a wire so it's very
very safe no one can pick up the
transmission like using a radio we're
overlooking some vital infrastructure
we're overlooking our solar panels we're
overlooking the water source of the pond
so it's key that we keep these areas
under our control and no one can mess or
damage our infrastructure so i have no
doubt we could handle 10 marauders even
groups of 20.
david has spent hours and hours creating
and assessing numerous contingency plans
if he or others are ever separated from
the compound he has designed a system of
hidden stores that will allow them to
survive and fight for days this is a
survival cache i put in i appreciate if
you don't get anything but the cachet so
we will not know where it is
i included a lot of things different
tools we also have mres along with the
number 10 cans different entrees this
will keep me and my family alive for a
few weeks no problem
i absolutely never live in fear
fear makes you go the wrong direction
but being prepared i know if i wake up
tomorrow and there's no money because
the
financial system has crashed to me it'd
be just another day i'd go out take care
of the chickens i'd go cut some firewood
and life for me would go on
david and scott your worst fears have
been realized the world has been plunged
into unimaginable economic chaos your
preparations are impressive you have
developed numerous nearby sources of
fresh water stored enough food to
survive initial economic shock waves and
cultivated enough land and bred enough
livestock to be self-sufficient for
years you have covered your critical
needs of communication fuel and
sanitation and you also have a clear
plan on how to maintain security and the
means to execute it
however our expert contends that your
compound might be too visible and would
lead outsiders to believe that you are a
high value target
you may want to explore how to better
hide your complex and increase the
numbers in your group
i i definitely don't agree with the
experts our farmhouse here is definitely
looks just like any other farmhouse you
drive by anything that we do to make us
more strong be it combat multipliers are
hidden so someone walking down the
street would not realize what they would
be going up against
the koblers and the hunts did not agree
with our expert assessment and have made
no additional efforts to lower their
visibility as a potential target
in the shadow of the majestic rocky
mountains peter larson has built a
weekend retreat for his family there are
a lot of people that have cabins my
cabin just happens to be buried
underground living in the constant fear
of a nuclear attack he works tirelessly
to safeguard his loved ones by preparing
for every possible contingency it
doesn't mean that i'm
an
extremist but are these extreme
preparations enough
peter larson is a traveling salesman who
lives in a neatly manicured suburb of
salt lake city with his wife children
and grandchildren his life is typical of
millions of americans
except i've spent a better part of my
life preparing for a nuclear holocaust
[Music]
he's a prepper
i believe there's
the very high probability of a nuclear
attack on on the u.s probably from the
hands of a terrorist the
greatest nightmare that i can
imagine is a nuclear holocaust where
terrorist organization that manages to
get their hands on a delivery system
that
enables them to detonate the weapon
of omaha nebraska
prepper is someone like myself who
prepares
and it doesn't mean that i'm an
extremist
i simply decided that it was time to get
a shelter for myself and my family
there's always a question of whether or
not i'll be able to actually get to my
shelter my shelter is about an hour and
20 minute drive from here
when there's a nuclear attack the
fallout would be going primarily to the
east as long as the prevailing winds
continue to move in that direction
subsequently
i have three rounds the rule of three
guides many prepper plans
peter has three modes of transportation
utilizing three different routes from
his home to a shelter to practice
worst-case scenarios peter will often
leave his car and walk the last several
miles to his bunker one of the things
about prepping is it has eliminated some
hobbies
i don't golf i don't bowl
i don't follow sports
most of my time is focused on what can i
best do to prepare my family for a
nuclear holocaust
this is my bug out bag carry it with me
everywhere i go
this bag has everything that i'm going
to need to
get myself back to my shelter
fire starting equipment i have a hand
chainsaw
water filtration
if we're dealing with a
with a breakdown in the system there's a
hostile environment it's important that
i have good clean water i'm actually
pumping this water through a ceramic
filter it's kind of like pumping water
through a rock so it's going to pretty
well protect me from anything that's in
the water i currently have about a
thousand gallons of water stored that'll
last us about two months by the end of
the summer i'll have another thousand
gallons that'll add another two months
peter is meticulous and relentless in
his planning
along each of his possible routes he has
hidden critical provisions
this one hidden on a friend's farm is
only a few miles from his bunker the
idea of a cash is simply to have
additional supplies located
along the way between my home and my
shelter
so that i can resupply myself with food
water and necessities
this is also a place i can spend the
night not only is it warm it's also
going to be dry and comfortable
a successful salesman peter travels
extensively
when he enters a new town or city he is
examining it through the dark prism of
his survival anytime i spend time in a
major metropolitan area i'm always
cognizant of the quickest way out
because i look at the cities quite
frankly as a death trap
my shelter is located in the foothills
in a remote part of the state this is
quite a paradise and i believe that in
the event of a nuclear holocaust this
will continue to be a paradise
this is my bunker i've specifically
designed it and stockpiled it for my
family
are people i suppose that look at this
and wonder why we would do such a thing
there are a lot of people that have
cabins my cabin just happens to be
buried underground
this unit is a 50 foot long steel
corrugated tube 10 foot diameter
in the floor
i have enough food
medical supplies water
clothing to last my family at least a
year
about five years ago i decided that it
was time to get a shelter for myself and
my family what are we having for dinner
ramen and mac and cheese we also use our
shelter as a weekend retreat and so
this becomes our our cabin in the woods
so to speak it's a place that
that we feel good just coming to
in the event of a nuclear holocaust it's
nice to have a place that you're
comfortable with
and
has that beauty and serenity
peter's extreme preparations to
safeguard his family from a nuclear
holocaust are never complete he's
constantly adding to his food and water
stockpiles
sharpening his survival skills
and spending more and more money and
time to strengthen his bunker
when the bomb drops i'm going to be 20
feet down in my shelter with my family
this door closed locked in place
it's capable of withstanding the
pressure of a fully loaded dump truck 80
000 pounds of pressure on this door
it'll protect me from virtually anything
that can happen
peter is always assessing new risks
potential dangers
and possible countermeasures
there are still
in the neighborhood of 2000 nuclear
weapons in the hands of the russians
trying to get me and check me chinese
are building up their nuclear stockpile
the iranians are coming on strong as
well as the north koreans
there are a lot of threats in this world
i think you just sold the farm my friend
our expert has determined that your
underground shelter has been
sufficiently reinforced to protect you
and 12 family members from a nuclear
blast as close as one half mile from
your site you have enough food to last
two years been extensively trained in
survival and self-defense skills and
your emergency evacuation plans are
extremely well thought out however our
expert calculates that you do not have
enough water stored to ensure your
survival six six months i do need three
thousand gallons of water i'll take care
of that also your job with its extensive
travel requirements breaks the prepper's
cardinal rule of never separating
yourself from your family and leaves you
in a very vulnerable situation
you know he's absolutely right
that that's something that i've been
uncomfortable with
and quite frankly it's time for me to
change jobs
peter has taken our experts advice and
has begun the process of acquiring and
storing additional water also
he is now actively looking for a new job
that keeps him
closer to home
most scientists economists and military
leaders feel that in the immediate
future the cataclysmic events described
in this show remain highly unlikely
however
currently government officials do
recommend a greater level of
preparedness and awareness to cope with
unanticipated events and disasters
[Music]
you